e aí galera chegando ao tudo com vocês
você sabe que está aqui só eu quero ver
vocês
galera estou aqui em são paulo gravando
com júlio canseira que todo mundo filho
vai gravar um tiro minhas férias e olha
aí que jogando assim o gay pra cima e
yero julho a cielo e michael bacall a
gente a falar de grilo rolar o show na
bolsa santa - 2005 pinto cup só tem um
golzinho que tive no jogo já sofre e se
dizer eu falei ficávamos vamos jogar só
bom vale um tiro entre o vão entre
cuiabá bola sair pela boca ainda jovem
para o hospital com a bala alojada no
kuwait onde a gente vai falar sobre o
assunto bem legal e adolescência à
puberdade é o pinto é basicamente sei só
que o que nasce e volta desses guy eu
lembro é quente lembra estava falando
ontem eu estava começando e eu também
sou filho mesmo problema que era todos
os meus amigos de cabelo sangue e como a
gente sabe que o amigo tem cabelo lançar
pegando o homem é muito escroto quando
nasce cabelo lançar ele quer mostrar pra
todo mundo tipo ele vem para assim
ajudar uma puxada e da puxada na cueca
na casa se ele fala aí o carro
automaticamente quando ele vira um olhar
dele vai pra cá depois volta é ele sim é
o filho da [ __ ] vagabunda nem lembro da
primeira vez que eu vi cabelo negocinho
de homem como eu estava estudando ou
estudando na escola aí na sala tipo
vãozinho assim enfim o que dá vontade de
pular seguranã aí eu fui amigo ela pulou
no que ela pulou a saia de ser só um
pouquinho e ver aquela grama sintética
saiu por cima ou por baixo não para cima
com o che tal quando saí de feu que deus
eu já que tem seu eu já visualizei
aquela grama sintética vegetação
rasteira nos daninhas ainda se cheguei
fora aí eu
vendo só pew de perto como é pequeno se
acha uma coisa legal é você acha topman
eu lembro quando começou a nascer os
noivinhos folha farmácia comprar um colo
e nem vou pintar não é só votar preto
poderá ficar legal chácara passa na moda
não analisava assim saiu ótimo pegar é
capaz a mocinha só que os 44 peninha é
bom andar onde é a minha sala sem querer
e não perdi um pelinho pm ano e agora
ele é também quando eu raspei a primeira
vez seu também é rapidinho escolher
bolinha me arrependi muito mal porque eu
fiquei tipo e agora está em uma
solenidade ela foi tomar banho porque
você quando você é 20 anos e você raspa
dá pra ver que você tinha quando você
tem 13 anos você queira os cabelos ar
você monta se uma criança não morre
quando minha mãe tá no banheiro ela
visse um monte de pilotos só vai saber
que define sacará que ela pensa de mim e
quatro filhos jogado no chão fiquei com
ele eu lembro mas só começou a ser
primeiro
meu cabelo do meu sacra foi bugado tipo
curiosa começou a sair primeiro rebola
ser pela bola e fez o primeiro do lado
depois da bola
aí foi fechando assim no meia uma bola
assim o placar ficou na casa de ana
lucia e foi subindo e foi subindo e
agora tá aí é só da amazônia toda tira
se depilou qo salvar a calçada sua vida
receber visita uma vez eu né primando
pelos akman a namorada na época conta a
menina e aí ela leva em casa não ficará
a área deixou deixar claro mcc passar o
seu e aí fui passando embaixo de um
literato itália terá estada ficar de
olho disse ver a mandou passar aqui
passei direto só sente por não podendo
nem pouco assim
na bola assim nem pelos cantinho à
olinda senhora me inspira sim mateus
pinaud m de altura de olhar como bonito
pra aquele max olhas impasse se fosse de
mulher eu comia não é o viu principal
dura e deixou barcelona pouco mas não
cuida de você
ai meu de desculpa galera é melhor um
dia meu cocô ró então não transei não
fiz nada mas dias depois que acontece
todos os pêlos na bunda e gravou
derrocada não bebeu com ele ontem saí
pra esse tema cachê civil se você tiver
gosto já sabe aquele gostei aqui no
youtube se você tiver sensibilidade do
facebook que vai e volta lá
clique em curtir com a ajuda de mais
barcos os amigos aí na portaria e
facebook reconhecer e comenta aqui
embaixo que você mais lembra o que mais
marcou a sua adolescência sua puberdade
em como é que embaixo se escreve o canal
quando perdi o vídeo está aqui
o canal do junho com cielo aqui ó
6 quem anda me que no mapa pouca fé e só
clicar aqui que vai diretamente para se
inscrever no canal dele conhecer ronaldo
julio conselho canal canal e é isso aí
muito obrigado valeu até a próxima falou
e phelps foi o pior